right so we'll work on the common
mistakes that n and we'll we'll do Jon
okay so first mistake is that you're on
this uh XY AIS stuff so he's going on
that way and I go that way that's
incorrect okay so you have to use your
iion to start the fight
rotating so yes he is got some spinal
penetration
but I'm not just getting out of the
way so for example if he's pulling right
he's pulling I still am bringing that
fight around with those IDE do you
understand okay so don't just rely on
getting out of the way because you can't
rotate the fight that way so remember
jodon passes through the other two
phases so Jon you have to go gon
[Music]
Chon get on Chon then into Jon and
that'll help you on uh that rotation so
get on chw on and then it'll go to
jodon get on chew on
Jon your step therefore is not at
12:00 it's probably going to be at 9 or
3 Bo pop Boom the fight
rotate boom pop
because we're here don't cut on his arm
you're on the outside checking for the
turn you don't want him turning and do
take downs and stuff like that so you're
controlling the turn
okay here control the turn not over the
top all right let's get
there so right now we're antagonistic to
each other I'm I'm going this way
stopping myself going this way right
he's going that way he doesn't want to
go backwards so that's why I rotate the
cross and I get to the back and now we
are going in the same direction but I'm
in the center of a
circle so that makes this
incorrect he's still coming this way I'm
still going that way it's not his job to
bend over for me and then I do my
okay you have to first
reconcile the set up contention point so
w here and now we're going the same way
you see that I'm behind him my hips are
with his hips my nose my spine my feet
are with him but I am now in the middle
of the Circle Drive so w't pop P looking
this way
different not
right okay get there
go okay so two things we're looking at
already is because we're rotating I'm on
the inside of the circle there is a a
centripetal energy that is working on
his head and a centrifugal energy that's
working on the lower part of his body
okay
the centrical energy is not being
generated here it's over here and with
my body so uh here and this iy adhesion
so here is how you control his
body not just his head his body his body
is
mov so why is that important one you're
going to need I adhesion skills on this
arm because you you don't want to hook
but you have to transfer your connection
point from the grip to the
neck here this has to be
there because that is my kazushi part
okay the kazushi is generated in the
following way so if I was doing cun Naga
it is my weight goes into my
hand same thing like he's trying to hold
my arm he's trying to pick my arm up
he's trying to pick my arm up
same thing I'm going to do that on his
neck I'm not trying to turn him
around from the
tilts I just dropped my hat
tilt boom tilt drop my
hand and then I stick to it the hand
s to the
[Music]
hand stick to the
hand don't yank
him boom get to the hand okay let's
go you have that little tilt there you
see that goes through her
Center not over her
foot little
tilt
but not over the
foot he's leaning in you see and this
hand here this starts compressing you
feel that on your
Center not over that
foot you got this angle you see remember
and right there this just compresses you
feel
that okay watch as I'm doing that that
is the
kazushi and then I stay up with him so
I'm here
going but I'm going to stay up with him
as he falls that's what you're mistaking
as the Ten con is making him fall
okay
no
compress and then I stay with his
hand with his
head
w
if you pay attention the t con is after
he already started
falling I'll show you if I don't do
it you came
around after
okay you don't want to tilt someone look
there it is Bo okay try it so in this
version without the t con uh i
t the foot Maneuvers for staying up on
the on the kazushi this thing is I
tend to kind of Shuffle to stay in the
back okay so we're here boom I drop if I
stay here look how I'm in the
front so as he
falls I'm in the back okay I don't want
to kneel down is he's going to try to
get up as he tries to get up that's when
I bring him
forward a
w in it's going to be
here enter feet together boom stay in
the
back stay in the back again face where
he is don't start contradicting his
motion keep your hip where he is he's
going to get up you go forward into the
checkin
boom gets up boom into the
Techni what I want here is the footwork
you see
it and then they're going forward into
your
chest we'll deal with the throw out
okay let's
try Okay so another detail on
thei W is he's going to get up you're
going to do KES on his head
so he wants to get up right or he wants
to turn into me so when you feel that
energy you go to the back and you keep
his going forward you see
that he goes up boom look at his
balance up he goes up I stay in the
back
don't start contradicting what we
already did he comes around under your
here he's got pretty good balance I'm
supposed to be here and he is supposed
to be here you see that
difference goes forward P
here
again you are aiming a falling body so
when I go
here he should already be
falling before I do what you think is he
not I go like this it's not
falling
don't come back to the front don't give
him back his
balance
go have to bring her forward into the
kazushi
your just go back your left arm went
dead it's part of the
control forward without it going all the
way around that one's better breathe get
a
[Music]
base
come around the neck even if you don't
have
to and have your arm alive even if
you're not using
it no you pivoted her on the front leg
that's fake you got to crush your
Center
down and move in back do it
again the fight moves you must move down
boom move in the back forward not
[Music]
backwards going to get up forward I'm
moving
backwards so I let his Center go up Mak
his Center go up okay same thing here
my chest my chest is controlling see
it's not I'm not holding him to me I'm
holding my chest to him and this part is
moving
hold don't try to bend him back just get
him where the center is in front now
this is a mistake cuz you're going to
feel his
weight you see that that's not even even
net cuz you didn't enter if you move in
place you'll never Advance got it so the
way you take off that
pressure is not by going around him but
his
whole
technique continuing to go forward don't
smell the throw don't smell the throw in
here this whole thing keep keeps making
a circle there's the
yield just like we've been doing on teni
nugget not
here
contact and the
yield you remember okay same exact thing
you're going to get
here boom forward there it is you're
going to have one more yield pull there
it go in that he keeps going forward and
he keeps going forward his head is going
backwards there keep it going
Bo do
not trade
stances wrong so wrong it's ridiculous
okay
go forward forward no no no no no no no
no no no her Center's got to get in
front before you do the
throw forward forward but you go
backwards
keep all here all here goes
down stay with her get up she go
forward he goes forward then I move
back again think C Das on the head they
should already be
[Music]
falling leg
straight lower
my I take her
forward forward but I go
backwards
then you feel that don't smell it keep
it going look this little yield right
there I'm going to shift my weight there
it is right
there